>> KAITLIN COLLINS, THANKS.
>>> NOT ALL OF THE NEWS BEING
MADE BY TESTIMONY TO THE JANUARY
6 COMMITTEE HAPPENED INSIDE.
NEW REPORTING FROM "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" UNDERCUTS WHO IVANKA
TRUMP SAID DURING RECORDED
TESTIMONY.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THIS COMMENT.
>> I RESPECT ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR.
SO I ACCEPTED WHAT HE WAS
SAYING.
>> I'M JOINED NOW BY "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" MAGGIE HABERMAN WHO
BROKE THIS STORY.
MAGGIE, WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING
THAT IVANKA TRUMP SAID TO
CAMERAS FILMING THIS DOCUMENTARY
LEADING UP TO JANUARY 6th THAT
DIFFERED FROM WHAT SHE TOLD THE
COMMITTEE?
>> SURE, JAKE.
WHAT SHE TOLD THE COMMITTEE IN
THAT SNIPPET, AND WE SHOULD BE
CLEAR THAT'S ONE OF THE FEW
PIECES THAT THEY HAVE RELEASED
SO FAR.
SHE SAT FOR A MUCH LONGER
INTERVIEW.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE IS
THERE.
SHE SAID THAT SHE WAS AFFECTED
BY BILL BARR, SHE RESPECTED HIM,
ET CETERA.
THAT WAS BASED ON A STATEMENT
BILL BARR MADE ON DECEMBER 1st,
2020, TO THE ASSOCIATED PRESS
WHERE HE SAID THERE WAS NO
WIDESPREAD FRAUD THAT IMPACTED
THE ELECTION, CONTRARY TO WHAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS SAYING AT THE
TIME, THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
FURIOUS WITH BARR FOR SAYING IT.
NINE DAYS LATER, ACCORDING TO
VIDEO THAT WE HAVE SEEN, IVANKA
TRUMP WAS RECORDED BY THIS
FILMMAKER IN AN INTERVIEW WITH
HIM, THIS PERSON MAKING SOME
KIND OF A DOCUMENTARY ABOUT
TRUMP AND ABOUT PEOPLE AROUND
TRUMP, TALKING -- YOU KNOW,
ASKED HER RESPONSE TO TRUMP'S
VIEW OF THE ELECTION AND SHE
ENDORSED THE IDEA THAT HE SHOULD
CONTINUE FIGHTING, THAT HE
SHOULD KEEP SEEKING EVERY LEGAL
REMEDY, LEGAL REMEDY WERE HER
WORDS.
SHE SAYS NOW THERE'S ALL OF
THESE QUESTIONS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ABOUT SORT OF THE SANCTITY OF
THE ELECTORAL PROCESS, WITHOUT
MENTIONING THE FACT THAT HER
FATHER'S FALSE CLAIMS ARE PART
OF WHY PEOPLE HAD THESE ISSUES.
SHE DID NOT USE THE WORD "FRAUD"
IN WHAT WE HEARD BUT SHE DID
SORT OF TOE THIS LINE THAT WAS
BEING ARTICULATED PUBLICLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE SHE
REALLY BELIEVED, BUT THOSE
WERE -- THOSE WERE WORDS THAT
WOULD MAKE HER FATHER VERY
HAPPY.
PEOPLE AROUND HER OFTEN POINT TO
SHE WAS IN A TOUGH POSITION.
SHE CERTAINLY WAS BUT IT WAS A
POSITION SHE PUT HERSELF IN.
THE VIEW OF STAFF IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND IN THE CAMPAIGN WAS
THE FAMILY NEEDED TO BE DOING
MORE TO TALK TO TRUMP THAN THEY
WERE.
INSTEAD IT WAS LEFT TO OTHER
PEOPLE TO TRY TO HANDLE THE
MESS.
>> HAS IVANKA TRUMP RESPONDED TO
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS DOCUMENTARY
VIDEO?
>> NO.
I REACHED OUT TO AN AIDE FOR HER
AND HAVE NOT HEARD BACK.
I'M NOT SURE THAT